I growin when I was putting this talk
together talk to bunch of people and I
said I'm giving a talk in Chicago
how can i pan it up audience and they
said well in Chicago the city has a flag
and it's everywhere and people love it
and I said do they love it so much they
would get angry if I were to desecrated
on my title slide and they said no
probably not that much and I said
perfect
so I'm Joel and I am the pit buzzin
tensorflow guy that's not all I am I'm a
research engineer at the Outlands tube
for artificial intelligence we are
hiring we're hiring in Seattle actually
we're located but it doesn't get cold
there in the winter and it's actually
really easy to find authentic Seattle
style pizza there I'm like here but
we're not very good at scenario
governors to prison I'm working on it
but we got some heading up dude before
that I was a software engineer at Google
and I did data science at a bunch of
startups and as mentioned I wrote a book
you can see it you should read it if you
have it it's pretty good right so I'm
here to talk to you about fizzbuzz in
case you're not familiar with it it's a
pretty simple programming problem write
a program the prints and numbers from 1
up to 100 except that if the number
sizzled by 3 instead of putting the
number of french fizz the number is
divisible by 5 instead of putting the
number print buzz and if the numbers
divisible by 15 instead of printing the
number print fizzbuzz so that's the
extent of the problem it's not that
complicated but some you know software
engineering places use it as a weed out
problem in their interviews figuring
that if you can't solve this problem
then you're probably not much of a
software engineer we're not to being
able to solve it proves that you are but
not being able to solve it demonstrates
that you really aren't and so the reason
I'm here is that I wrote a blog post
about a guy so I called me who goes on a
job interview and gets asked to solve
this fizzbuzz problem
and feels moderately insulted being
asked to solve this is less problem so
it decides to dive into it and solve it
using tensor flow very obviously to his
interviewers wishes it's pretty good
blog post I encourage you to check it
out first draft of this talk was me
standing up here reading it to you but
the people are enough I didn't like it
so I decided not to do that
but to sum it up with a meme solve is
buzz using tensorflow didn't get the job
but there's more to it you should check
it out anyway why that blog post I blog
you know like 4 times a year but why
that one oh well I saw another Lane
discussion about what's the stupidest
way to solve this buzz I thought I gotta
come up with a stupid away than that
came up with a stupider way the blog
post kind of went viral young-looking
tweeted it out dean shared it on its
Google+ everyone got really into it and
it's kind of a frivolous thing to use my
15 minutes of fame on but that's ok I
use it on something and so because I
want what my big heroes is Andy Kaufman
I wrote it in a way that it's kind of
hard to tell if it's a true story or if
it's not a true story
in fact at work last week people are
like did that really happen
well I cannot good diet but and so
because of that the comments on the blog
post actually got pretty good too you
know where people started arguing about
whether they would hire me
and then other people like then to
defend me you know one guy called me an
expert which I don't think I've ever
been called before so that was pretty
exciting for me too but I was probably
most of you know this has a really
simple solution if you're doing high
school like I like to do it looks like
this and since this is PI data here's
the equivalent Python solution which
looks pretty identical so that's really
the extent of fizzbuzz as a problem but
I've still got some time left
so as a as a computer science problem as
a programming problem it's not that
exciting
but it's a machine learning problem it's
actually kind of interesting um so
machine learning you want to build a
model that will take an input and
predict some output
what will our out be I thought about it
here I said you know what there's four
cases you say the number is is you safe
is you say buzz you safe is buzz
so one natural way to represent that is
a vector of like four it's the park
predicted probability for each of those
four cases seems like pretty good so
that's what I want with and once we do
that we can define a ground truth
function that looks a lot like our
solution to the problem itself usable by
15 put a 1 in the fourth spot say this
will by 5 put a 1 in the third spot and
so on and so this is the function that
we want to learn with the machine
learning model now that we know what we
want to predict we have to decide what
are we going to use as our features as
I'm sure a lot of you know feature
selection it is a difficult important
part of solving machine learning
problems here one thing we can do is we
could cheat and what do I mean by
cheating I mean here we know that
divisible by 3 and divisible by 5 are
the essence of the problem and so we use
those are features one of our features
is is the thing that is all by 3 is this
divisible by 5 and you know maybe it's
not cheating maybe that's just being
cluttered so what would that
do you didn't do anything in the back
for this microphone is there gonna go
okay great so one thing is for any
number just create an array that has is
this number divisible by three is it
divisible by five and then I stuck a one
in there to make the math easier as well
and so if you use those as your features
it's really easy to come up with a
solution
here's a simple matrix multiplication to
compute fizzbuzz as I'm sure most of you
guys know and then you just do that
multiplication and pull out which is the
largest ever this is not a machine
learning solution because I came up with
that matrix by hand but it has a very
machine learning kind of feel to it in
the sense that taking these inputs
multiplying them by matrix and then
looking for the biggest stopper and no
it's hard to imagine an interviewer who
wouldn't be impressed by even like a
simple solution like that and now you're
probably starting that being thinking
what what the heck is that and where
does those numbers come from and how on
earth is that a solution to fist butts
and so all that is is if you think of it
divisible by three axes and are
divisible by five axes it's actually
just measuring how far in each of those
four diagonal directions the input is
and so whichever one's largest gives you
the right case clever
it says clever looks like and so then
you know what if you're not that clever
in this case because we know about the
problem we know that divisible by three
is important visible by five is
important but what if we didn't know
that at the top of our heads what if we
just had the data and not the rule
behind it so you know what what natural
thing to try the first thing that
occurred to me to try was just turn each
number into binary so you're gonna do
all the numbers up to ten 23 that just
gives you 10 zeros and ones and that
could be the input to your model in the
comments of the blogpost someone else
suggested doing a one hot encoding of
the digits so here near the first row is
a three second row the one third rows of
five and so on so then you turn a
three-digit number into thirty zeros on
ones so I decided I would try both of
those
and then because we're good can a data
scientist machine-learning practitioners
we don't want to train on our test data
so if the goal is to do this for 1 to
100 let's train on data that's not 1 to
100 so binary the rest of em is 101 10
23 decimal 101 999 and then we can use
separate training and test sets
who knows how neural networks work
everyone someone I'll go there real fast
in case a few people don't but basically
you get some inputs you take those
inputs in the simple case you multiply
them by some weights you do some
computation on the inputs and you apply
an activation function so in your
stereotypical neural network you
multiply your books by weights you add
them up and then you pass them through a
sigmoid function although no one does
that anymore or a real unit or something
but anyway this is how neural networks
are basically set up and so the talk is
called fizzbuzz and tensorflow
so let me walk you through the extent of
what I know about tensor fun which is
mostly contained on this slide you need
to do some imports and those are the
standard conventions you set up a couple
placeholder screen data you define some
parameters you want to learn you define
some parametric model of your data and
your parameters you apply the model to
the symbolic variables you set up some
training operation by minimizing some
cost function you create a session you
initialize variables you train using
data so um as you can see you got to a
bottom code and I actually didn't even
say what the model was yet so that's
just before I've even written out my mom
so since I wrote the blog post I've
gotten into Karis which is a much nicer
API that sits on top of tensorflow and
also a piano and so the rest of this
will be done in Karis but I used the
tensorflow back end so it's still in
intensive so so compared with what I
just showed you here
here's the equivalent one side procerus
again you import a couple of things I
want to punch a bottle and some layers
here I'm actually defined the model
ident
Rayleigh you activation and Slater
softmax don't don't sweat it if you
don't know what all those things mean I
compile the model by saying here's the
optimizer I want to use here's my loss
function and then I fit them on so even
if you know nothing about neural
networks and deep learning it's pretty
clear that that's a much simpler and and
friendlier API use and it's easier to
iterate on and get things store so
that's what we'll be using but fizzbuzz
and karent's didn't have the same ring
to it so I left the talk title as is and
I hope no one's super disappointed about
that and then the other thing I just our
goal with was okay I'm making all these
predictions how do I want to visualize
the results and what I came up with it's
not easy but it's kind of the best I
could
so from left to right those are the
numbers 1 to 100 which we're making our
predictions for and then there are 4
vertical rows the first row is number as
is second row fist
third row plus fourth row fizzbuzz
anytime you see a black dot that means
we predicted that output correctly
anytime you see a red dot that means we
predicted that output incorrectly and
the blue dot is what we should have
predicted for that number so here you
can see one was predicted correctly for
two we predicted buzz fits in the third
row we should have predicted just the
number itself and so on so stare at this
graphic for a minute because it'll be a
bunch of these and then because those
are hard to make sense of I've also got
cross gaps as you can see at the bottom
right each row is a prediction each
column is an actual so numbers along the
diagonal are good numbers that are not
on the diagonal are bad and we'll just
take this visualization in these cross
tabs and look at some different models
and see when they work and when they
don't and why did you why they don't so
it turns out that we need regression
is a neural network with no hidden
layers and the linear activation
function so I have a bunch of inputs x1
x2 x3 I multiply them by weights
I add some bias term I decide them up
that's when your regression so I can do
that in Kerris that's just a dense layer
so if I define a model that's just a
dense layer with ten inputs are ten
dollar digits and four outputs that
gives us a linear regression model and
if I compile it with mean squared error
loss and train it this is the outcome
with a binary inputs it learns to always
predict the number set the best it can
be
there's not enough representational
power there for it to figure anything
better outs with the decimal it does a
little bit better as you can imagine
when you have the decimal representation
of a number it's very easy to figure out
when a number is divisible by five and
when it's not and so it learns to always
predict buzz whenever it's visible by
five and so it gets the fizzbuzz is
wrong but it gets the the buzzes right
so that's cool
I'm sorry to say it's easy to learn to
school by five similarly you can do a
logistic regression as a neural network
it's basically the same thing except at
the end we pass it through a logistic
function in this case because all we're
doing is looking what is the output with
the largest value it's essentially the
same model with just a slightly
different loss function and so it learns
basically the exact same thing again it
always predicts the number for the
binary inputs and it always pretty
exposed when something is divisible by
five for the decimal point so those are
not very interesting models but now we
can get and do the sort of models that
you actually need you know a Karass or
times of law or Theano for the neural
networks with hidden layers so here's a
pretty simple you know one hidden layer
vanilla in neural nets you can see has
got a dense layer and activation layer a
dense layer and then a softmax layer
softmax it's just a way of taking the
outputs and turning them into
probabilities and from here on out I'm
only going to worry about the binary
input
because the decimal ones actually
they're good at learning divisible by 5
and they're really terrible at learning
everything that's not that so here's
what happens when you train the one
hidden layer network with various
numbers of hidden neurons so you can see
with five hidden neurons it doesn't want
anything again not enough power at ten
it starts learning a little bit of
things but still is not doing very well
once heat up to 25 then it's actually
doing pretty pretty nice it's only got
six of them wrong and you can see as you
go on it kind of bounces around a little
bit it tends to overfit to the training
set so even as you add more neurons it's
still not getting perfect because you've
over fit the training set each time and
then you know the last thing to try is
deep learning it's pretty trendy and
everyone's to do deep learning so to do
deep learning we just add another hidden
layer with some dropouts which will help
us with overfitting
but again that's all it takes to set up
the model in carrots and then training
it the same way so what happens to be do
these hidden layers uh you do 100 in
both hidden layers you get to about 95%
actually in the training set and when
you get to you know 2,000 my two
thousand ten layers then you can get it
exactly right but there's some
randomness involved so it doesn't always
work but so okay I got a neural network
that can you know solve this fizzbuzz
problem I give it a binary number and it
figures out he's this number divisible
by five is it divisible by three is it
divisible by 15 that's cool but you said
to me hey I want you to you know give me
some weights that will take binary
inputs and tell me whether they're
divisible by 15 but I have no idea how
to do that so I was curious you know can
we look under the covers and see what
these are actually doing so obviously
when you have you know two thousand
units in the first hidden layer two
thousand units in the second layer
you're talking about millions of
parameters and you're not gonna have
much luck trying to make sense of
so what's the what's the simplest model
we found that was actually interesting
the simplest model was this 25 hidden
Iran neural net it got all the divisible
by 15 exactly right and so I wanted to
understand okay I have all these uh you
know binary inputs how is it learning
divisible by 15 like it's doing
something kind of interesting but what
what's it doing this interesting so I
said okay you know one way I can
approach this is to say before I do my
soft max every input is spitting out
four numbers and so I could just ask
what are the inputs that spit out the
largest number in that fizzbuzz column
so I just took my took all my inputs one
to 1024 and sorted them by that output
in that last column CNC four fifty three
ninety two seventy three thirty three
hundred seven eighty four eighty three
sixty and these are all divisible by 15
which is good I mean this way doesn't
have to work all you really needed
because grading soft max is for that
last column to be bigger than all the
other columns but here when you just
look at which inputs make that last call
on the biggest in an absolute sense you
get a bunch of visible by 15 which is
nice so clearly it's learning this
divisible by 15 means stick something
large in the last column okay well how
is it doing that one thing to notice or
one thing that you'll you will you might
notice if you stare at this for a long
time is that you get a lot of parents
that differ by a hundred int1 they get
almost identical output so if you look
at what is the output for 450 it's very
close to the output for 330 which is 120
less okay what is the output for 270
it's very close the output for three
nine which is you know 120 and so when I
have whenever I had found these two
pairs of numbers on the previous page
that differed 120 they were producing
very similar outputs across the board
and so why would it be doing that and so
I thought about it some more and I
realized if you have two numbers that
differ by any multiple of 15 then
necessarily they have the same fizzbuzz
output if one is visible of like 50 and
the other one will be two if one's
divisible by 5 but not 15 the other one
will be 2 once this will play three but
not 15 the other one too and if it's not
too little why either neither will be
the other one so if you had a network
that can learn to ignore differences
that are multiples of 15 or multiples of
30 or multiples of 45 then number
whatever a real head start towards
learning how to predict fizzbuzz and it
would only have to learn in an extreme
case if you had a network that always
did the same thing whenever two numbers
differ by 15 and it did the right thing
when it saw 15 then it would
automatically do the right thing for
every multiple of 15 right so there's
very few equivalence classes for 15 so I
said okay 450 was like the largest value
of that forth output what are the other
inputs whose outputs are closest to that
450 output so this is a very awkward
title first slide I couldn't figure out
a better way to reword it but these are
the inputs for which the outputs are
close to the output for 450 and so I
said okay how does each of these things
relate to 450 well look at 3:30 and so I
looked at what are the binary
representations of these things if I hit
330 its plus 8 minus 128 from 450 so
obviously it takes the fourth bit and
the 8 bit and flips them took 195 its
plus 1 minus 256 from 450 so it takes
the first pin in the ninth bit and flips
them and if I look at 480 it's minus 2
plus 32 from 450 again it takes
the second bit and the sixth bit and
flips them so when I discovered when I
dug into this is that there's actually a
lot of a common bit flips where you take
two bits and swap their values that end
up being multiples of 15 and so what
that means is if you have a network that
treats those two bits the same then
whenever you get those differences of
120 or whatever the network's gonna do
the same thing on those and it certainly
looks like that's what this network
learned to do and so to take it even a
little bit further let's just look at
what happens when we flip those two pics
for a bunch of different inputs so if I
take 8 and I flip the plus 8 minus 128 I
get to 128 you can see that the outputs
of the last dense layer look almost
identical 9 to 129 again 10 to 130 again
and for every one of these parents where
I got there by flipping those 2 bits
I got basically very similar outputs for
the entire network and now you know 11
and 12 they don't look anything alike 12
and 13 they know anything alike but
somehow the network has learned I'm
going to ignore all these 120
differences that are gotten this way and
that's actually happening earlier in
network 2 i feel sort of guilty for
making you stare at big tables or
numbers but this is a the output of the
first dense layer if I look at 8 and 128
the bold ones are the positive numbers
and they all are pretty close I feel
like at 15 and 135 the Bolton ones are
the positive ones and again they look
pretty close too so it seems like that's
really what this network is doing is
learning is identifying these you know
differences of multiples of 15 that I
can identify by flipping a bit and then
just learning to ignore them and this
also kind of suggests one reason why
binary encoding does a lot better for
all the non divisible by 5 problems
which is that
if I can learn that flipping this one
bit should stay the same
well that's going to help me you know
crease the same thing for 800 and 28 for
330 and 450 for a lot of different
inputs whereas if you look at what would
I need to learn in the decimal world
well suddenly I'm not flipping bit so
I'm turning to off and turning to on and
free trade on 128 the four bits like to
touch are totally different from 3:30
and 4:15 four bits I have to touch so I
can't learn these like simple flips that
work for large lots of numbers I have to
learn individual chips and it's much
more difficult and it's not a very
complete explanation but it's subjective
and and I thought it was pretty
interesting
so what were my lessons learned from
this project one it's hard to turn the
joke blog post in your talk to feature
selection is really important but we
already knew that that's not really a
lesson learned it's a lesson reiterate
here also a stupid problem sometimes
contain really interesting subtleties
and sometimes black box models will
reveal those subtleties you look at them
in the right way
and if anyone came expecting just purely
a joke talk I apologize that I included
actual science and data and things like
that and that's what I've got so the
code is up on my github it's not in a
great state but I'll get it in a great
state if you want to find the blog post
it's on my blog I'll tweet out a link to
these slides after this talk is over and
you know there's a small possibility I
might add a chapter about the slides to
my book so you should probably buy that
just in case - and with that I'll take
any questions anyone's got
so the question is how I thought about
applying Ella seems to this and the
answer is at this stage in like my deep
learning practice I'm really good at
like dense layers but I haven't really
wrapped my head around LST M's and
recurrent networks and memory networks
and things like that and so I'm like I'm
trying to learn all that stuff but I'm
not at the point where I would have
tried it on this problem yet but I will
right
okay so the question was have I thought
about taking this train Network and
applying it to other problems and the
short answer is that the networks i've
been playing with don't even get
fizzbuzz exactly right so I'd be
surprised if they did real well on other
problems that are further away from it
but it's an interesting idea and I'm
gonna go think about it but I've thought
about much
what is his buzz plus um no I mean I I
think there's a good point that there
it's easy to think of a broader class of
problems which is here's a pattern and
like figure out here's a pattern in some
examples and figure out the pattern and
here it's not really taking advantage of
that it's just like here's a here's a
dump of you know a thousand examples can
you predict one hundred more but with
some of the you know interactive
sequential learning that could do
someone problems like that it's not it's
not obvious to me why them I've put make
it harder but it's possible
um so when okay so so there's what I say
I was trying to represent it as
basically zeros and ones where as prime
factorization
I mean you then it's suddenly like you
you've got to get the powers of in their
representation right so I mean there's
there's no reason you couldn't do that
like my gut tells me that I don't like
taking data where it's like 2 means 2
factors of 3 and 3 means 3 factors of 3
and 4 means four factors of 3 and
putting it into like a neural network
type model but I can't really give you
like a good explanation for that like
just somehow my gut feeling is that like
that's not a right representation
yeah so the the suggestion wants to
train one network just for good as well
by three and another network just for
divisible by five and then just combine
the two and so so so a couple things yes
it feels like that might work too that
kind of falls along though it's closer
to what I call cheating which is not
cheating but which is I know a lot about
this problem so I'm going to design a
network that's really geared towards
this problem
Oh
yeah I think that I'm probably work but
I haven't read it either the other
questions
all right thanks everybody for coming